Our episodes deal with serious and often-distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis center. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings Please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website On the afternoon of Friday, May 31, 1985, Bob Smith sat in his home office. The father of three ran a business selling electronic scoreboards and signs, a job that provided the flexibility to work from home. The arrangement was particularly welcome on this unseasonably hot day,
我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集的节目说明。1985年5月31日，星期五下午，鲍勃·史密斯坐在他的家庭办公室里。这位三个孩子的父亲经营着一家销售电子记分牌和标牌的企业，这份工作让他可以灵活地在家办公。在这个异常炎热的日子里，这种安排尤其受欢迎，
as it allowed Bob to relax by the pool with his wife before sitting down to do some work. At around 3.30pm, Bob looked out the window. His office was on the second floor of his family's South Carolina home, with views over the expansive front yard of their large rural property. At the end of the 750-foot-long driveway, Bob saw the familiar side of his daughter's blue Chevy Shavette hatchback. The car belonged to 17-year-old Sharon Phase Smith, or Shari as she preferred to be called. Shari was returning home from a
因为这让鲍勃在坐下来工作之前，能和妻子在泳池边放松一下。下午3点30分左右，鲍勃向窗外望去。他的办公室位于他家南卡罗来纳州住所的二楼，可以俯瞰他们大片乡村房产宽阔的前院。在750英尺长的车道尽头，鲍勃看到了他女儿那辆熟悉的蓝色雪佛兰Shavette掀背车。这辆车属于17岁的莎伦·费伊·史密斯，或者按她喜欢的称呼，叫莎莉。莎莉正从
pool party at the home of a classmate. As was her habit, she stopped at the end of the driveway to check the mailbox before heading down to the house. Bob got back to work. But after five minutes or so, the house was noticeably quiet. Shari usually burst in eager to say hello to her parents and tell them about her day. Bob looked outside and to notice that Shari's chavette was still idling at the end of the driveway. He wondered if she had received a letter and was reading it in her car. Minutes passed and Shari's car didn't budge. Bob got a bad feeling.
一位同学家的泳池派对返回家中。按照习惯，她在前往房子之前，会在车道尽头停下来检查邮箱。鲍勃回到工作中。但大约五分钟后，房子里安静得有些反常。莎莉通常会兴冲冲地跑进来，急着和父母打招呼，讲述她一天的经历。鲍勃向外看去，注意到莎莉的Shavette仍然停在车道尽头，引擎空转。他心想，她是不是收到了信，正在车里读呢。几分钟过去了，莎莉的车一动不动。鲍勃有一种不祥的预感。
Shari had a rare disease called diabetes insipidus, commonly known as water diabetes. The condition was characterized by a hormone malfunction that prevented Shari's kidneys from retaining water, resulting in extreme thirst and frequent urination. Without her medication or large quantities of water, Sherry was under the constant threat of severe and even fatal dehydration. Therefore, she never went anywhere without her medication. Bob considered whether Sherry could have ducked behind a nearby bush to urinate. The Smith's driveway jutted off Plattsprings Road, a long stretch roughly 10 miles outside
莎莉患有一种罕见的疾病，叫做尿崩症，俗称“水糖尿病”。这种疾病的特征是激素功能障碍，导致莎莉的肾脏无法保留水分，从而导致极度口渴和频繁排尿。如果没有药物或大量的水，莎莉将时刻面临严重甚至致命的脱水威胁。因此，她从不随身不带药。鲍勃考虑莎莉是否可能躲在附近的灌木丛后小便。史密斯家的车道从普拉特斯普林斯路延伸出来，这是一条距离
the town of Lexington. It was a quiet spot surrounded by woodland, and sherry could have easily relieved herself without anyone noticing. Worst case scenario, she might have become dehydrated and disorientated, or maybe even lost consciousness. Not wanting to take any chances, Bob jumped into his own car and quickly drove to the end of the driveway. The engine of Sherry's car was still running. The driver's side door was open, and male was scattered on the ground.
列克星敦镇约10英里的长路。这是一个被林地环绕的安静地点，莎莉很容易就能在不被任何人注意的情况下解决内急。最坏的情况是，她可能脱水并迷失方向，甚至可能失去知觉。鲍勃不想冒险，他跳进自己的车，迅速开车到车道尽头。莎莉车的引擎还在运转。驾驶座一侧的车门开着，邮件散落在地上。
Bob got out of his car and appeared inside of Sherry's Shavette. The keys were still in the ignition and the damp towel she'd taken to the pool party lay across the driver's seat. Beside it, on the passenger seat, sat Sherry's handbag. Her medication and wallet were inside. The sandals she'd been wearing that day were sitting on the floor. Bear footprints led from the car to the mailbox, but they stopped there. Shari herself was nowhere to be seen. scene. Bob Smith and his wife Hilda assured the police that Shari had no reason to run off.
鲍勃下了车，向莎莉的Shavette里面看去。钥匙还在点火开关里，她带去泳池派对的湿毛巾横在驾驶座上。旁边，在副驾驶座上，放着莎莉的手提包。她的药和钱包都在里面。她那天穿的凉鞋放在地板上。赤脚的脚印从车一直延伸到邮箱，但到那里就断了。莎莉本人不见踪影。鲍勃·史密斯和他的妻子希尔达向警方保证，莎莉没有理由离家出走。
She was in the prime of her life, set to graduate from high school with honours in just a few days. Sherry was a talented singer and she'd been given the honour of singing the National Anthem at the school's graduation ceremony. She'd been looking forward to it immensely. A born performer, Sherry had been accepted to study music at Columbia College in South Carolina later that year. In the meantime, she and her graduating classmates would be celebrating the end of their schooling with the crews to the Bahamas. For her parents, the only explanation for Sherry's disappearance was that something terrible had happened.
她正值花季，几天后就要以优异的成绩从高中毕业。莎莉是一位才华横溢的歌手，她获得了在学校毕业典礼上演唱国歌的殊荣。她一直非常期待这一刻。作为天生的表演者，莎莉已获准于当年晚些时候在南卡罗来纳州的哥伦比亚学院学习音乐。与此同时，她和毕业班的同学们将通过去巴哈马群岛的游轮旅行来庆祝学业结束。对她的父母来说，莎莉失踪的唯一解释就是发生了可怕的事情。
Sherry was particularly close to her older sister, 21-year-old Dawn, who was already living away from home while studying. The siblings shared a love for singing and often performed a gospel favour at Suriante Lexington. Collectively known as the Smith Sisters, they aimed to carve a career for themselves in the Christian music industry. As soon as Shari disappeared, an officer was summoned to collect a dawn from the nearby city of Charlotte and drive her back to Lexington. Dawn admitted to police that her father was strict,
莎莉与她21岁的姐姐道恩特别亲近，道恩已经在校外独立生活。姐妹俩都热爱唱歌，经常在列克星敦的教堂表演福音歌曲。她们被称为“史密斯姐妹”，目标是在基督教音乐行业开创一番事业。莎莉失踪后，一名警官立即被召集去附近的夏洛特市接道恩，并开车送她回列克星敦。道恩向警方承认，她的父亲很严厉，
and that this could sometimes be a source of thanks for Shari. Shari had occasionally expressed a desire to go stay with Dawn, but never under any circumstances did Dawn think her little sister would take off on her own. There's was a close-net family, and although Shari craved a bit more freedom, she knew her parents always had her best interest at heart. Even on the unlikely chance that Shari could have run away, she wouldn't leave her life-saving medication behind. Police didn't believe the Smiths had anything to hide, and they wasted no time in launching a full-scale missing person's investigation. Within hours, hundreds of locals braved the sweltering heat
这有时会成为莎莉的压力来源。莎莉偶尔表达过想去和道恩住在一起的愿望，但道恩绝不认为她的小妹妹会独自离家出走。他们是一个关系紧密的家庭，虽然莎莉渴望多一点自由，但她知道父母总是为她着想。即使莎莉真的离家出走，她也不会丢下救命的药物。警方不认为史密斯一家有什么隐瞒，他们立即展开了全面的失踪人口调查。几小时内，数百名当地人冒着酷暑
to traverse the rugged terrain surrounding the Smith's Taneca property. Police looked for tire tracks, shoe prints, or anything else that could provide a clue as to Sherry's whereabouts. They found nothing. Had Sherry become disorientated due to her medical condition, they didn't think she would have wandered far.
穿过史密斯家房产周围崎岖的地形。警方寻找轮胎痕迹、鞋印或任何能提供莎莉下落线索的东西。他们一无所获。如果莎莉因为病情而迷失方向，他们认为她不会走远。
A member of the search party was checking Platt Springs Road about half a mile from the Smith home when they found a red bandana. It was believed to belong to Shari. Police wondered whether she could have intentionally left it behind as some sort of clue. As the hours passed with no sign of the teenager, police became steadfastly convinced that Shari's disappearance wasn't the result of her diabetes. Someone had taken her against her will. Someone had taken her against her will. The last person to see Shari was her boyfriend, Richard Lawson. The two had spent the morning in downtown Lexington organizing travelers checks for Shari's
搜救队的一名成员在距离史密斯家约半英里的普拉特斯普林斯路检查时，发现了一条红色头巾。据信这属于莎莉。警方怀疑她是否可能故意将其留下作为某种线索。随着时间流逝，这名少女仍无踪影，警方坚定地认为莎莉的失踪并非糖尿病所致。有人违背她的意愿带走了她。有人违背她的意愿带走了她。最后见到莎莉的人是她的男友理查德·劳森。两人在列克星敦市中心度过了上午，为莎莉的
upcoming cruise. Once they were done, Shari left her Shavette in the shopping center car park and drove in Richard's car to their friend's pool party. The couple spent a few hours there before Shari called her parents at around 2.30pm to say she was about to head home. Shari and her younger brother, 15-year-old Robert, were expected to check in with their parents every now and then to keep them in the loop of their plans.
即将到来的游轮旅行整理旅行支票。完成后，莎莉把她的Shavette留在购物中心停车场，开着理查德的车去了朋友的泳池派对。这对情侣在那里待了几个小时，之后莎莉在下午2点30分左右给父母打电话，说她准备回家了。莎莉和她15岁的弟弟罗伯特被要求不时与父母联系，让他们了解自己的行程。
Police cast a suspicious eye on Richard Lawson, but Sherry's family didn't think there was any chance he would cause her any harm. Sherry adored Richard. He was an upstanding young man, and the two were head over heels in love. They'd both been accepted to Columbia College and were excited to be starting the next chapter of their lives together. Regardless, police questioned Richard. He said that after leaving the pool party, he dropped Shari back to her car in downtown Lexington. The two sat in her car talking for about 15 minutes.
警方对理查德·劳森投以怀疑的目光，但莎莉的家人认为他绝不可能伤害她。莎莉深爱着理查德。他是一位品行端正的年轻人，两人正处于热恋中。他们都被哥伦比亚学院录取，并对共同开启人生的下一个篇章感到兴奋。尽管如此，警方还是审问了理查德。他说，离开泳池派对后，他把莎莉送回了列克星敦市中心的车里。两人在车里坐着聊了大约15分钟。
After that, Richard said he kissed Shari goodbye and got back into his own car. They shared the same rude home, so Richard trailed behind Shari for a while before turning off in the direction of his own home. According to Richard, he went straight home and didn't leave the house thereafter. His alibi checked out. This put Shari arriving home alone at around 3.30pm. Some passes by had seen her standing at her mailbox about to appear inside. They hadn't noticed anything odd or suspicious, but they did recall seeing an
之后，理查德说他吻别了莎莉，回到了自己的车里。他们回家的路相同，所以理查德在莎莉身后跟了一段路，然后转向了他自己家的方向。据理查德说，他直接回了家，此后就没再出门。他的不在场证明经核实无误。这意味着莎莉在下午3点30分左右独自到家。一些路人看到她站在邮箱旁，正准备查看里面的东西。他们没有注意到任何奇怪或可疑的事情，但他们确实记得看到一辆
unusual vehicle in the neighborhood around this time. The car was described as a late model old mobile or Pontiac in a cranberry colour. One witness recalled glancing in their review mirror and seeing the vehicle stop in the Smith's driveway. They caught a glimpse of the driver, describing him as a male aged in his 30s. When they drove past again about 10 minutes later, Sherry's car was still there, but Sherry herself wasn't. Given that the Smith's male was scattered on the ground, police theorized that Sherry's abductor had accosted her at the male box shortly after Bob Smith looked away from the window
不寻常的车辆在附近出现。这辆车被描述为一辆深红色的后期款奥兹莫比尔或庞蒂亚克。一位目击者回忆说，在后视镜中看到这辆车停在史密斯家的车道上。他们瞥见了司机，描述他是一名30多岁的男性。大约10分钟后他们再次开车经过时，莎莉的车还在那里，但莎莉本人不见了。鉴于史密斯家的邮件散落在地上，警方推测，在鲍勃·史密斯从窗户移开视线后不久，莎莉的绑架者就在邮箱处袭击了她。
of his home office. The fact that Bob hadn't witnessed to the incident was sheer bad luck. By all accounts, Sherry Smith was a popular, well-liked and vibrant young woman. She was actively involved in her school community and had been recently voted Widiest Girl by her senior class. As a devoted member of Lexington's first Baptist church, she took her faith very seriously and wasn't involved in drugs or any nefarious behavior. But to police, this didn't seem like an opportunistic attack. If Sherry hadn't been targeted by a known enemy, police speculated whether someone could
鲍勃没有目击到这一事件纯属不幸。据各方描述，莎莉·史密斯是一位受欢迎、讨人喜欢且充满活力的年轻女性。她积极参与学校社区活动，最近还被高年级同学评为“最机智的女孩”。作为列克星敦第一浸信会的虔诚成员，她非常认真地对待自己的信仰，没有参与任何毒品或邪恶行为。但对警方来说，这看起来不像是一次机会主义的袭击。如果莎莉不是被已知的敌人盯上，警方推测是否有人
have followed her home. The blonde-haired blue-eyed Sherry was described as strikingly attractive. Someone could have noticed her either before or after the poor party and been captivated by her physical appearance enough to covertly watch and trail her vehicle. Or perhaps they'd been stalking Sherry for a while. Sherry worked part-time at a local flea market. Police learned that just two weeks prior, a male customer had been kicked out of the market for harassing Shari and other young women. The Smiths were an influential family in Lexington. Shari's
跟踪她回家。金发碧眼的莎莉被描述为非常迷人。有人可能在泳池派对之前或之后注意到了她，并被她的外表所吸引，以至于暗中观察并跟踪她的车辆。或者，他们可能已经跟踪莎莉一段时间了。莎莉在当地的一个跳蚤市场兼职。警方获悉，就在两周前，一名男性顾客因骚扰莎莉和其他年轻女性而被赶出市场。史密斯一家在列克星敦是有影响力的人家。莎莉的
father Bob volunteered as a chaplain for the Sheriff's Department, as well as the county jail and youth correctional facilities. He and his wife Hilda are often saying hymns to those incarcerated, and they were sometimes joined by Sherry and Dawn. Police considered the possibility that a former inmate could have developed an obsession with Shari and attract her down upon their release. Alternatively, what if an inmate had it out for Bob Smith and targeted Shari as part of some deranged revenge plot? Inquiries were made into former inmate to had crossed paths with Bob or Shari Smith, but there was no evidence to implicate any of them in the
父亲鲍勃自愿担任警长部门、县监狱和青少年管教所的牧师。他和妻子希尔达经常为囚犯唱赞美诗，莎莉和道恩有时也会加入。警方考虑了前囚犯可能对莎莉产生痴迷并在获释后跟踪她的可能性。或者，如果某个囚犯对鲍勃·史密斯怀恨在心，并将莎莉作为某种疯狂复仇计划的目标呢？警方对曾与鲍勃或莎莉·史密斯有过交集的前囚犯进行了调查，但没有证据表明他们中的任何一人与
kidnapping. With no obvious suspects emerging, police considered whether Sherry's abduction could have been financially motivated. The Smiths weren't particularly wealthy, but the income they earned through Bob's electronic sales and Hilda's part-time work as a substitute teacher afforded them a comfortable lifestyle with an impressively large house. Although the family seemed like an unlikely choice to target, police had to consider what if Sherry had been kidnapped for ransom.
绑架案有关。由于没有明显的嫌疑人出现，警方考虑莎莉的绑架是否出于经济动机。史密斯一家并不特别富有，但他们通过鲍勃的电子产品销售和希尔达作为代课老师的兼职工作获得的收入，让他们过着舒适的生活，并拥有一栋令人印象深刻的大房子。虽然这个家庭看起来不太可能是目标，但警方不得不考虑莎莉是否被绑架以勒索赎金。
Later that night, as the search for Sherari continued, the Smith's home phone rang. On the other line was an unknown male. I have Shari, he said. I want money. Anticipating a call of this nature, police had installed a phone tap which allowed them to trace the call to a phone booth in an undisclosed location. The caller was identified as 27-year-old Edward Robertson, but any hopes that Shari would be returned were short-lived when the call was determined to be a hoax.
那天晚上晚些时候，随着对莎莉的搜寻继续，史密斯家的电话响了。电话另一端是一个陌生的男人。“我有莎莉，”他说。“我要钱。”预料到会有这种性质的电话，警方安装了电话窃听器，这使他们能够追踪到电话来自一个未公开地点的电话亭。打电话的人被确认为27岁的爱德华·罗伯逊，但当电话被确定为恶作剧时，莎莉能被送回的任何希望都破灭了。
Robertson was hit with multiple charges, including extortion and obstruction of justice. The bogus ransom was a huge waste of police resources for a case where time was well and truly of the essence. Without Sherry's medication, there was the very real possibility that she could become dehydrated enough to slip into a coma. When there was no sign of Sherry Smith by the following morning, planes equipped with infrared technology were sent down by the FBI.
罗伯逊被控多项罪名，包括勒索和妨碍司法公正。对于一个时间极其紧迫的案件来说，虚假的赎金要求是对警方资源的巨大浪费。没有莎莉的药物，她极有可能因脱水而陷入昏迷。到第二天早上仍没有莎莉·史密斯的踪迹时，联邦调查局派出了配备红外技术的飞机。
Authorities from surrounding counties were brought into assist while a trailer was set up in front of the Smith family home to act as investigation headquarters. Led by Lexington County Sheriff James Matt, the search for the 17-year-old quickly became the largest manhunt in South Carolina's history. A report came in that Sherry had recently been threatened by some other students from her high school. Police looked into these claims and questioned every other guest who attended the pool party with Shari the day before, but no further leads emerged. By Sunday, the full weight of Shari's disappearance was
周边县的当局被请来协助，史密斯家门前搭建了一个拖车作为调查总部。在列克星敦县警长詹姆斯·梅茨的领导下，对这名17岁少女的搜寻迅速成为南卡罗来纳州历史上最大规模的搜捕行动。有报告称，莎莉最近受到高中其他学生的威胁。警方调查了这些说法，并询问了前一天与莎莉一起参加泳池派对的每一位客人，但没有发现进一步的线索。到周日，莎莉失踪的沉重感
felt as her high school graduation ceremony went ahead without her. Classmates couldn't ignore the enormity of this situation as a chair reserved for Shari Sadampty and the National Anthem was performed by another student. A friend of Sh family is missing. When Lexington local Betty Harris, not her real name, saw the media coverage of Sherry's disappearance, it sparked a memory. On the afternoon of Friday, May 31, Betty had been driving down Platte Springs Road when she saw a young blonde woman walking towards her mailbox.
随着她的高中毕业典礼在没有她的情况下举行而愈发强烈。同学们无法忽视这一情况的严重性，莎莉的座位空着，国歌由另一名学生演唱。莎莉家的一位朋友失踪了。当列克星敦当地人贝蒂·哈里斯（化名）看到关于莎莉失踪的媒体报道时，她想起了一件事。5月31日星期五下午，贝蒂开车经过普拉特斯普林斯路时，看到一名年轻的金发女子正走向她的邮箱。
A man was approaching. A couple of minutes later, Betty was continuing down the road when she saw the blonde from the mailbox in the passenger seat of a reddish-colored car. It was being driven by a male who looked to be between 35 and 40 years of age, with a medium build and receding like colored hair. The car overtook Betty before slowing down to a point that she was forced to be of her horn. Betty could see that the man was distracted by his female passenger.
一名男子正在靠近。几分钟后，贝蒂继续沿路行驶，看到邮箱旁的那位金发女子坐在了一辆红色汽车的副驾驶座上。开车的是一名看起来在35到40岁之间、中等身材、浅色头发后移的男子。这辆车超过了贝蒂，然后减速，迫使她按喇叭。贝蒂可以看到那个男人被他的女乘客分散了注意力。
She didn't think much of it until she saw the news and realized that the man was distracted by his female passenger. She didn't think much of it until she saw the news and realized that the young woman she'd seen was Sherry Smith. The composite sketches of the man provided by Betty and other witnesses were notably different. However, their descriptions of his cranberry vehicle were all similar. However, their descriptions of his cranberry vehicle were all similar. Instead of focusing on identifying the suspect by his appearance, police focused on identifying his car. They collated a list of anyone Shari associated with who drove a similar vehicle, including attendees at her church.
她没多想，直到看到新闻，意识到那个男人被他的女乘客分散了注意力。她没多想，直到看到新闻，意识到她看到的年轻女子就是莎莉·史密斯。贝蒂和其他目击者提供的男子合成素描明显不同。然而，他们对那辆深红色车辆的描述都很相似。然而，他们对那辆深红色车辆的描述都很相似。警方没有专注于通过外貌识别嫌疑人，而是专注于识别他的车。他们整理了一份与莎莉有往来且驾驶类似车辆的人员名单，包括她教堂的参加者。
But as the search rolled into its third fruitless day, grave concerns were held for Sherry's welfare. Even if her kidnapper hadn't caused Sherry any harm, they'd need to be giving her copious amounts of water to ensure her survival. It had been an agonizing couple of days for the Smith family. They gathered in their home, comforted by a passing procession of concerned friends and relatives who brought their meals and to join them in prayer. A team of investigators stationed themselves on the property around the clock, ready to act the moment any potential lead came through.
但随着搜寻进入第三天且毫无进展，人们对莎莉的安危深感担忧。即使绑架者没有伤害莎莉，他们也需要给她提供大量的水以确保她生存。这对史密斯一家来说是痛苦的几天。他们聚集在家里，得到了一批又一批关心的亲友的安慰，他们送来食物并加入他们的祈祷。一组调查人员全天候驻扎在房产周围，准备在任何潜在线索出现时立即采取行动。
The Lexington community was on edge. Parents kept watchful eyes on their children, while young women avoided going out alone, fearful of the unknown. Then, at 2.20am on Monday, June 3rd, Sherry's father, Bob, was awoken from a restless sleep by the ringing of the phone. Bob answered, The muffled distorted voice of an unfamiliar man was on the other line. He asked to speak to Mrs. Smith.
列克星敦社区处于紧张状态。父母密切关注自己的孩子，年轻女性避免独自外出，害怕未知。然后，在6月3日星期一凌晨2点20分，莎莉的父亲鲍勃从不安的睡眠中被电话铃声惊醒。鲍勃接听了电话，电话另一端是一个陌生男人低沉、扭曲的声音。他要求与史密斯夫人通话。
Bob beckoned to his wife Hilda and she picked up the receiver. It was the call they'd been waiting for. The man claimed that he had Shari. To prove this wasn't a hoax, he described in detail the outfit that Shari had been wearing at the time she went missing, right down to the black and yellow bikini she had on underneath. The man assured Hilda that her daughter was fine. She was eating and drinking plenty of water. The man said he was going to release Shari.
鲍勃示意妻子希尔达，她接过了听筒。这就是他们一直在等待的电话。该男子声称他有莎莉。为了证明这不是恶作剧，他详细描述了莎莉失踪时穿的衣服，甚至包括她里面穿的黑黄相间的比基尼。该男子向希尔达保证她的女儿很好。她正在吃东西并喝大量的水。该男子说他打算释放莎莉。
The Smiths would be receiving more information in a letter from Shari that would arrive at 2pm the following day. In the meantime, the caller concluded, They are looking in the wrong place, tell Sheriff Matt to get on Channel 10 at 7am and call off the search. At the time, technology required a caller to be on the phone for 15 minutes before their location could be ascertained. Given the call was short, an instant trace couldn't be established.
史密斯一家将在第二天下午2点收到莎莉的一封信，里面会有更多信息。与此同时，打电话的人总结道：“他们找错地方了，告诉梅茨警长在早上7点打开10频道，取消搜寻。”当时，技术要求通话者在电话上保持15分钟才能确定其位置。鉴于通话时间很短，无法进行即时追踪。
After some time, the call was traced to a phone booth outside of a grocery store approximately 12 miles from the Smiths home. Officers rushed to the scene, but the booth was empty. A dust-for-fingerprints revealed no discernible clues. Investigators weren't entirely sure what to make of the call. The details about Sherry's bikini hadn't been reported on, which added credibility to the call as claims. But beyond that, the alleged captor hadn't provided any concrete evidence to prove that he had Shari, or that she was in-data live. Furthermore, he hadn't made any ransom demands, which raised
一段时间后，电话被追踪到距离史密斯家约12英里的一家杂货店外的电话亭。警官们冲到现场，但电话亭是空的。指纹采集没有发现明显的线索。调查人员不确定该如何看待这个电话。关于莎莉比基尼的细节此前并未报道，这增加了电话的可信度。但除此之外，所谓的绑架者没有提供任何确凿证据证明他有莎莉，或者她还活着。此外，他没有提出任何赎金要求，这引起了
questions about the purpose of his call. Regardless, the police were taking no chances. The owner of the Lexington Post Office was alerted, and at 4am, he was joined by two officers to collectively shift through every piece of mail addressed within the county. It was a painstaking task. The hours ticked by with no sign if the supposed letter, leading to doubts as to whether it existed at all. Then, at 7 a.m., success.
关于他打电话目的的疑问。无论如何，警方没有冒险。列克星敦邮局局长接到通知，凌晨4点，两名警官加入，共同筛选了县内寄出的每一封邮件。这是一项艰苦的任务。时间一分一秒过去，没有那封所谓信件的迹象，导致人们怀疑它是否真的存在。然后，在早上7点，成功了。
Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. This episode of Case file is sponsored by BetterHelp. How many times have you found yourself falling exhausted into bed looking forward to a good night's sleep, only to find that your brain won't stop talking. Believe me, I know just how overwhelming and frustrating those racing thoughts can be. But one thing I've learned is that talking these thoughts through can be a great way to turn them off.
案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。本集《案件档案》由BetterHelp赞助。你曾多少次发现自己精疲力竭地躺在床上，期待着睡个好觉，却发现大脑停不下来？相信我，我知道那些赛跑般的思绪是多么令人不知所措和沮丧。但我学到的一件事是，把这些想法说出来是关闭它们的绝佳方式。
Therapy gives you a place to do that, so you can get out of your negative thought cycles and find some mental and emotional peace. Therapy isn't just for those who've experienced major trauma, it's helpful for learning positive coping skills and how to set boundaries, it empowers you to be the best version of yourself. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online and flexible so it fits into your life. To get started, all you have to do is fill out a brief questionnaire and you'll be matched with a licensed therapist, and you can switch therapists any time for no additional charge.
心理咨询为你提供了一个这样做的地方，这样你就可以摆脱负面的思维循环，找到一些心理和情感上的平静。心理咨询不仅适用于经历过重大创伤的人，它还有助于学习积极的应对技巧和如何设定界限，它使你有能力成为最好的自己。如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，试试BetterHelp。它完全在线且灵活，因此适合你的生活。要开始，你所要做的就是填写一份简短的问卷，你将与一位持证治疗师匹配，并且你可以随时免费更换治疗师。
Get a break from your thoughts with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com-casefile-today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp-h-e-l-p.com-casefile. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. The white legal-sized envelope was addressed to the Smith family home in scrolling handwriting. Inside was a two-page letter written on yellow legal paper signed by Shari Smith. Dated June 1st at 3.10am, the title of the letter gave investigators pause. Written in cursive at the top of the page were the words, Last Will and Testament.
用BetterHelp从你的思绪中解脱出来。访问BetterHelp.com-casefile-today，首次购买可享受10%的折扣。那是BetterHelp-h-e-l-p.com-casefile。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持《案件档案》继续提供高质量的内容。白色的法律尺寸信封上用潦草的笔迹写着史密斯家的地址。里面是一封写在黄色法律用纸上的两页信，署名是莎莉·史密斯。日期为6月1日凌晨3点10分，信的标题让调查人员停顿了一下。页面顶部用草书写着：“最后遗嘱”。
The letter began. I love you, mummy, daddy, Robert, Dawn, and Richard and everyone else. I'll be with my father now, so please, please don't worry. Just remember my witty personality and a great special times we all shared together. Please don't ever let this ruin your lives. Just keep living one day at a time for Jesus. Some good will come out of this. As the letter continued, Sharia apologized for any disappointment she might have caused
信的开头写道：“我爱你们，妈妈、爸爸、罗伯特、道恩、理查德以及其他所有人。我现在要和我的天父在一起了，所以请，请不要担心。只要记住我机智的个性和我们共同分享的美好时光。请永远不要让这件事毁了你们的生活。只要为了耶稣，一天一天地活下去。这会带来一些好的结果。”随着信件继续，莎莉为她可能造成的任何失望道歉，
and urged someone else to take her place on the upcoming cruise. She reiterated how proud she was of her family and how much she loved them all. The letter concluded, I know you all love me and will miss me very much, but if you'll stick together like we always did, you all can do it. Please do not become hard or upset. Everything works out for the good for those that love the Lord. There was no return address. When Bob Smith was shown the letter, a desperate helplessness washed over him. He immediately recognized the handwriting as his
并敦促其他人代替她参加即将到来的游轮旅行。她重申了她为家人感到多么自豪，以及她多么爱他们所有人。信的结尾写道：“我知道你们都爱我，会非常想念我，但如果你们像我们过去那样团结在一起，你们都能做到。请不要变得冷酷或沮丧。万事都互相效力，叫爱神的人得益处。”没有回信地址。当鲍勃·史密斯看到这封信时，一种绝望的无助感席卷了他。他立即认出这是他
daughters. The caller had been right. This was no hoax. But it wasn't just the title of the letter or the final farewells it contained that escalated concerns about the abductors intentions for Shari. At the end of one paragraph, she'd written in parenthesis the haunting words. Casket closed. A cursory examination of the letter revealed no fingerprints or any other identifying clues. All investigators had to go by was the postage stamp, a commemorative duck decoy. But this was of little help as the stamp was a relatively recent design and was currently in wide circulation.
女儿的笔迹。打电话的人是对的。这不是恶作剧。但不仅是信的标题或其中包含的最后告别升级了对绑架者意图的担忧。在一段的末尾，她用括号写下了令人毛骨悚然的话：“棺材盖上。”对信件的初步检查没有发现指纹或任何其他识别线索。调查人员唯一能依靠的是邮票，一枚纪念鸭子诱饵邮票。但这几乎没有帮助，因为邮票是相对较新的设计，目前在广泛流通。
Although the envelope did confirm one helpful detail, it was postmarked June 1 from the city of Columbia, just 13 miles east of Lexington. Wherever Shari had been taken, it couldn't be too far. The letter was immediately sent for detailed forensic testing, a process that could take weeks. In the meantime, Bob and Hilda Smith made an impassioned plea on television, with Bob urging, Whoever it is that has our daughter, Sherry, we want her back. We miss her. We love her.
虽然信封确实确认了一个有用的细节，但它盖有6月1日的邮戳，来自距离列克星敦以东仅13英里的哥伦比亚市。无论莎莉被带到了哪里，都不会太远。这封信立即被送去进行详细的法医鉴定，这个过程可能需要数周。与此同时，鲍勃和希尔达·史密斯在电视上发出了恳切的呼吁，鲍勃敦促道：“无论谁带走了我们的女儿莎莉，我们都想要她回来。我们想念她。我们爱她。”
Please send her back home where she belongs. Hilda ratted. She is so important to us. Nothing in the world is more important. Right now, all we ask is just whoever you are, send Shari back home. A $15,000 reward for information was announced with one officer declaring, the search is not going to stop as long as there is hope. Anticipating that Shari's abductor would call again,
“请把她送回她所属的家。”希尔达哭诉道。“她对我们太重要了。世界上没有什么比这更重要的了。现在，我们唯一的请求就是，无论你是谁，把莎莉送回家。”有人宣布提供15,000美元的线索奖励，一名警官宣称：“只要还有希望，搜寻就不会停止。”预料到莎莉的绑架者会再次打电话，
investigators set up a recording device on the Smith family's home phone. If he did make contact, the Smiths were advised to keep him on the line for as long as possible. At 308pm at that same Monday, the phone rang. Shari's sister Dawn answered, It was the same male caller from earlier. He asked to speak to her mother. Have you heard anything to mail today? Uh, yes I have.
调查人员在史密斯家的电话上安装了录音设备。如果他确实联系了，史密斯一家被建议尽可能让他保持在线。当天星期一下午3点08分，电话响了。莎莉的姐姐道恩接了电话，是之前那个男声。他要求与她母亲通话。“你今天收到邮件了吗？”“呃，是的，我收到了。”
Can you please me now? Well, I'm not really sure I'll believe you because I haven't had any words of sharing. And I need to know that sharing is well. You'll know in two or three days. One, two or three days. Call the Serk's call. The call was soon traced to a payphone at a pharmacy in Lexington. There was no sign of the caller or any discernible clues.
“你现在能相信我了吗？”“嗯，我不太确定我会相信你，因为我没有收到莎莉的任何消息。我需要知道莎莉很好。”“你两三天内就会知道的。”“一、两三天？打给……”电话很快被追踪到列克星敦一家药店的公用电话。没有打电话的人的踪迹或任何明显的线索。
However, the location itself was of particular interest. The pharmacy was part of the same shopping centre where Sherry had parked her car while attending the pool party on Friday. This added weight to the theory that Sherry's abductor might have spotted her that day and followed her home. The Smith family didn't know what to make of this turn of events. While the contents of Sherry's ladder were deeply troubling, they refused to give up hope that she could still be found alive.
然而，地点本身特别令人感兴趣。药店与莎莉周五参加泳池派对时停车的购物中心是同一个。这增加了莎莉的绑架者可能那天发现了她并跟踪她回家的理论。史密斯一家不知道该如何看待这一事态发展。虽然莎莉信件的内容令人深感不安，但他们拒绝放弃她可能还活着的希望。
Maybe her harrowing words were meant as some kind of code. At 807 that same night, the phone rang again. When Dawn answered, she immediately recognized the voice of her sister's kidnapper. He asked Dawn if she had come down from Charlotte. Dawn said yes and asked who she was speaking to. The caller ignored her and said, I need to speak to your mother. Tell her to hurry. Hilda picked up. The caller asked, did you receive the letter today?
也许她那令人揪心的话语是某种代码。当天晚上8点07分，电话再次响起。当道恩接听时，她立即认出了她妹妹绑架者的声音。他问道恩是否从夏洛特下来了。道恩说是，并问她在和谁说话。打电话的人无视她，说：“我需要和你母亲说话。告诉她快点。”希尔达接了电话。打电话的人问：“你今天收到信了吗？”
Hilda responded that she had. To prove it, the caller asked her to tell him one thing that the letter said. Sherry had drawn a love heart with a combination of hers and her boyfriend Richards' names in it. Hilda told the caller this, confirming that the two-page letter was written on yellow legal paper. The caller stated, Okay, so you know now that this is not a hoax call.
希尔达回答说收到了。为了证明这一点，打电话的人让她告诉他信里说的一件事。莎莉画了一个爱心，里面有她和男友理查德的名字。希尔达告诉了打电话的人这一点，确认了两页信是写在黄色法律用纸上的。打电话的人说：“好吧，所以你现在知道这不是恶作剧电话了。”
He then asked why he's request for Sheriff Matt's to call off the search hadn't been Matt, saying, I'm trying to do everything possible to answer some of your prayers, so please in the name of God, work with us here. Hilda spoke kindly to the man, asking if he could just tell her whether Shari was okay without her medicine. The caller said that Shari was drinking two gallons of water per hour and going to the bathroom afterwards. He told Hilda he had to hurry as he knew the calls were being traced. This has gone too far, he said.
然后他问为什么他要求梅茨警长取消搜寻的要求没有得到满足，说：“我正在尽一切可能回答你们的一些祈祷，所以请以上帝的名义，配合我们。”希尔达温和地对那个人说话，问他是否能告诉她莎莉在没有药的情况下是否还好。打电话的人说莎莉每小时喝两加仑水，之后去洗手间。他告诉希尔达他必须快点，因为他知道电话正在被追踪。“这太过分了，”他说。
Please forgive me. The caller told Hilda to have an ambulance ready at their home. He claimed that if anything happened to Sherry, in addition to her request for a closed casket, she wanted to have her hands crossed over her chest as though in prayer. Listen to us please, the caller employed. Forget Lexington County. Look in Saluda County, do you understand? Sherry Faye requests no strangers when we give the location.
“请原谅我。”打电话的人告诉希尔达准备好救护车。他声称，如果莎莉发生了什么事，除了她要求闭棺外，她还希望双手交叉在胸前，仿佛在祈祷。“请听我们说，”打电话的人恳求道。“忘了列克星敦县。去萨卢达县找，明白吗？莎莉·费伊要求我们提供位置时不要有陌生人。”
Hilda reassured the caller that nobody was going to cause any harm. She just wanted to know whether Sherry was with him. The caller said he couldn't tell Hilda that, but, quote, I want to tell you one other thing. Shari is now part of me, physically, mentally, emotionally, spiritually. Our souls are one now. Hilda begged the caller to tell Shari how much her family loved her and that they do anything to make her happy. Again, the caller repeated his demands to have an ambulance ready.
希尔达向打电话的人保证，没有人会造成任何伤害。她只是想知道莎莉是否和他在一起。打电话的人说他不能告诉希尔达，但是，“引用：我想告诉你另一件事。莎莉现在是我的一部分，身体上、精神上、情感上、精神上。我们的灵魂现在合二为一了。”希尔达恳求打电话的人告诉莎莉她的家人有多爱她，他们会做任何事让她快乐。打电话的人再次重复了他的要求，要准备好救护车。
Healder urged him to call back again later that night, saying, God bless you for taking care of my baby. The caller continued, God bless you for taking care of my baby. The caller continued. I got to go now. Listen, listen. Please, please, forgive me for this. It just got out of hand. Cherry is protected now.
希尔达敦促他那天晚上晚些时候再打来，说：“上帝保佑你照顾我的宝贝。”打电话的人继续说：“上帝保佑你照顾我的宝贝。”打电话的人继续说：“我得走了。听着，听着。请，请，原谅我。这只是失控了。莎莉现在受到保护了。”
She is part of me now. And God look after all of us now. Good night. The cryptic phone call left investigators scrambling for answers. The kidnapper still hadn't provided any proof of life, and it remained unclear whether Shari had been harmed or not. The call was traced to a gas station just off the Interstate 20 highway, approximately eight miles from the Smith's home. But again, the caller had left behind no evidence. Although the information gained thus far did allow renowned FBI criminal profiler John Douglas
“她现在是我的一部分了。愿上帝保佑我们所有人。晚安。”这通神秘的电话让调查人员忙于寻找答案。绑架者仍然没有提供任何生存证明，目前尚不清楚莎莉是否受到了伤害。电话被追踪到距离史密斯家约8英里的20号州际公路旁的一个加油站。但同样，打电话的人没有留下任何证据。虽然到目前为止获得的信息确实让著名的联邦调查局犯罪侧写师约翰·道格拉斯
to put together a 22-point profile of the perpetrator. According to Douglas, Sherry's abductor was a white male, most likely in his mid to late 20s, but possibly in his early 30s. He was single, but had probably been married in the past or had a history of failed relationships. If he had a child of his own, that child would no longer be in his custody. He would either live alone or with parents or older relatives. This wouldn't be the perpetrator's first crime. He likely had a criminal record that included anything from making obscene phone calls and
能够拼凑出肇事者的22点侧写。据道格拉斯说，莎莉的绑架者是一名白人男性，很可能在20多岁中期到后期，但也可能是30岁出头。他是单身，但过去可能结过婚或有失败关系的经历。如果他有自己的孩子，那个孩子将不再由他监护。他要么独自生活，要么与父母或年长的亲戚住在一起。这不会是肇事者的第一次犯罪。他可能有犯罪记录，包括从打淫秽电话和
peeping and prying to full-blown sexual assault. He'd keep trophies taken from his victims. He'd have a penchant for pornography, with a particular lust for bondage and a sadomasochism. The evidence indicated that Sherry Smith had been taken by force, likely at knife for gunpoint. This indicated that the perpetrator wasn't particularly charming or attractive, as he knew he wouldn't be able to lure Shari into his car through any other means. He was likely overweight and suffered from low self-esteem. His crimes would be motivated by his
偷窥到全面的性侵犯。他会保留从受害者那里拿走的战利品。他会有色情癖好，特别迷恋束缚和施虐受虐狂。证据表明莎莉·史密斯是被强行带走的，很可能是在刀或枪口下。这表明肇事者并不特别迷人或有吸引力，因为他知道他无法通过任何其他方式诱骗莎莉上车。他可能超重，自尊心低。他的犯罪动机是
prevailing fantasy of exerting power over unattainable women. He likely picked female victims that he had no chance of a relationship with in his daily life, therefore forging a sense of power and control. Those victims would likely be children or young girls, as he'd find adult women to intimidating. Investigators determined that the perpetrator was using a variable speed control device to alter the sound of his voice. This indicated a knowledge of electronics that suggested the perpetrator likely worked
他试图对无法触及的女性施加权力的普遍幻想。他很可能选择了在日常生活中没有机会建立关系的女性受害者，从而建立一种权力和控制感。这些受害者很可能是儿童或年轻女孩，因为他会觉得成年女性太令人生畏。调查人员确定肇事者正在使用变速控制装置来改变他的声音。这表明他具备电子学知识，暗示肇事者可能从事
in electrical contracting, a job that provided flexible hours and the freedom to move around. Although the device distorted the caller's voice, it couldn't disguise his slight southern accent. In his first phone call, the perpetrator had told Hilda Smith to expect a letter from Sherry at 2pm. Two o'clock was their usual male delivery time. This in addition to the perpetrator's knowledge of
电气承包工作，这份工作提供灵活的时间和四处走动的自由。虽然该装置扭曲了通话者的声音，但无法掩盖他轻微的南方口音。在第一次通话中，肇事者告诉希尔达·史密斯期待莎莉在下午2点寄来的信。两点是他们通常的邮件投递时间。这一点，加上肇事者对
the surrounding counties and his use of various payphones, gave John Douglas no doubt that the offender lived locally, or was at the very least familiar with the area. The perpetrator knew that Dawn Smith had travelled down from Charlotte. He'd also used Sherry's middle name, Faye. Did this mean he knew the Smith family on a personal level? The payphone locations also suggested something else of note. Each call had come from a different location and each area had been wiped clean.
周边县的了解以及他使用各种公用电话，让约翰·道格拉斯毫不怀疑罪犯住在当地，或者至少熟悉该地区。罪犯知道道恩·史密斯从夏洛特赶来。他还使用了莎莉的中间名，费伊。这是否意味着他从个人层面认识史密斯一家？公用电话的位置也暗示了其他值得注意的事情。每次通话都来自不同的地点，每个区域都被清理干净了。
The fact that the offender knew his calls were being traced, coupled with his use of a voice-altering device, indicated a knowledge of forensic proceedings. Whoever he was, investigators were dealing with someone of above-average intelligence. John Douglas determined that the perpetrator was meticulous and obsessive in his daily habits. He likely had everything planned out, with the tone of his voice hinting that he was reading from a script. He was a rigid thinker who probably had an unsuccessful previous career in the military. Sheriff James Metz told reporters, a feel we're looking for an extremely sharp individual in one regard and an extremely
罪犯知道他的电话正在被追踪，加上他使用变声装置，表明他了解法医程序。无论他是谁，调查人员都在处理一个智力高于平均水平的人。约翰·道格拉斯确定肇事者在日常习惯上是细致且强迫性的。他很可能计划好了一切，他的语调暗示他是在照本宣科。他是一个思维僵化的人，可能在军队中有过不成功的职业生涯。詹姆斯·梅茨警长告诉记者：“我觉得我们在寻找一个在某方面极其敏锐，而在另一方面极其
psychotic individual in another regard. He seems to be almost schizophrenic, one who thinks clearly and acts irrationally. traditionally. By Tuesday June 4, the investigation into Shari Smith's disappearance rolled into its fourth day. Convince that the perpetrator was following the story in the media, the Smith family made another television appeal for Shari's safe return, with Dawn telling her sister, we're not a family without you. Hilda had it. Shari, we love you so much.
精神病态的人。他似乎几乎是精神分裂症患者，一个思维清晰但行为非理性的人。”到6月4日星期二，对莎莉·史密斯失踪的调查进入了第四天。确信肇事者正在媒体上关注这个故事，史密斯一家再次在电视上呼吁莎莉平安归来，道恩对她的妹妹说：“没有你，我们就不再是一个完整的家庭了。”希尔达补充道：“莎莉，我们太爱你了。”
We're just not going to give up on finding you. I know you're being taken care of. We just feel such assurances from the Lord that you will be with us again. Amphithetic of their plight, the community continue to rally behind the Smiths, with volunteers distributing over 10,000 missing person posters around town. Concerned citizens contributed to the reward pool, increasing the amount to $25,000. Still, nothing led to the identity of Sherry's kidnapper.
我们绝不会放弃寻找你。我知道你现在有人照顾。我们从主那里感受到了强烈的保证，你一定会回到我们身边。社区民众对史密斯一家的遭遇感同身受，纷纷给予支持，志愿者们在镇上散发了超过一万张寻人启事。热心市民也向悬赏金池捐款，将金额提高到了25,000美元。然而，依然没有任何线索指向雪莉绑架者的身份。
By 9 o'clock on Tuesday night, over 24 hours had passed since the offender last made contact. The Smith family sat on edge and able to sleep as they awaited further instructions that they weren't even sure would come. Then, at 9.45pm, the phone finally rang. Dawn answered it. It was Sherry's abductor. He asked a dawn to put Hilda on the other line and to grab a pencil and paper. This is Sherry's own words, he said.
到了周二晚上9点，距离罪犯最后一次联系已经过去了24个多小时。史密斯一家如坐针毡，彻夜难眠，等待着他们甚至不确定是否会到来的进一步指示。终于，在晚上9点45分，电话响了。道恩接了电话。是雪莉的绑架者。他让道恩叫希尔达接听另一部电话，并准备好纸笔。他说：“这是雪莉的原话。”
So listen carefully. Say nothing unless you're asked. I know these calls are taped and traced, but that's irrelevant now. There's no money demanded, so he is Sherry Faye's last request. On the fifth day to put the family at rest, Sherry Faye being freed. Remember, we are one soul now. Then put the family at rest, sherry-faye being freed. Remember, we are one soul now. When located, you'll locate both of us together.
“所以仔细听。除非我问你，否则什么都别说。我知道这些电话都被录音和追踪了，但这现在无关紧要。没有索要赎金，所以这是雪莉·费伊最后的请求。在第五天让家人安心，雪莉·费伊将被释放。记住，我们现在是一个灵魂。然后让家人安心，雪莉·费伊将被释放。记住，我们现在是一个灵魂。找到的时候，你们会同时找到我们两个。”
We are one. God has chosen us. Respect or past and present requests. The caller told the women to jot down the actual times and events. He said the kidnapping happened at 3.28 p.m. on Friday, May 31, and that sherry quote, had the fear of God in her. At 3.10 a.m. on Saturday, June 1, she wrote her last Will and Testament. At 4.58am, the two, quote, became one soul. Hilda asked the caller what he meant by that. He continued, no questions now, and instructed
“我们是一体的。上帝选择了我们。尊重我们过去和现在的请求。”来电者让女士们记下具体的时间和事件。他说绑架发生在5月31日星期五下午3点28分，并称雪莉“对上帝怀有敬畏之心”。6月1日星期六凌晨3点10分，她写下了最后的遗嘱。凌晨4点58分，两人“合二为一”。希尔达问来电者这是什么意思。他继续说：“现在别问问题”，并指示
them to have an ambulance ready between 4 and 7 o'clock the following evening. Prayers and relief coming soon, he said. Please learn to enjoy life. Forgive. God protects the chosen. Again, he ordered Sheriff Matt to call off the search, adding, Blessings are near. You will receive last instructions where to find us. Hilda pleaded with the man not to kill her daughter. He ignored her,
让他们在第二天晚上4点到7点之间准备好救护车。“祈祷和解脱很快就会到来，”他说。“请学会享受生活。宽恕。上帝保护被选中的人。”他再次命令马特警长停止搜查，并补充道：“祝福就在眼前。你们会收到关于在哪里找到我们的最后指示。”希尔达恳求那个男人不要杀她的女儿。他无视了她，
concluding, we love and miss you all, get good rest tonight, goodbye. The call was traced to a payphone at a convenience store at Lake Murray, nine miles from the Smith Zone. Again, no fingerprints or other evidence had been left behind. Officers established roadblocks in the area, but nothing brought them closer to identifying the perpetrator or finding Sherry.
总结道：“我们爱你们，想念你们所有人，今晚好好休息，再见。”电话被追踪到位于默里湖一家便利店的公用电话亭，距离史密斯家九英里。同样，现场没有留下指纹或其他证据。警官们在周边地区设立了路障，但没有任何进展，无法确定肇事者或找到雪莉。
Based on the callers instructions, police feared that they could be dealing with a murder suicide. However, behavioral profiler John Douglas believed that the perpetrator was, quote, 2. Full of himself and his perceived power to take his own life. Based on his pattern of promising and withholding information, Douglas thought it was more likely that the kidnapper had already killed Shari, but didn't want to reveal the location of her body because he was continuously returning to visit her corpse. Whatever the case, investigators needed to be ready for when the next call came the following
根据来电者的指示，警方担心这可能是一起谋杀自杀案。然而，行为分析专家约翰·道格拉斯认为，肇事者“太自负，沉迷于自己夺取他人生命的力量”。基于他承诺又隐瞒信息的模式，道格拉斯认为绑架者更有可能已经杀害了雪莉，但不想透露尸体的位置，因为他一直在回去探望她的尸体。无论如何，调查人员必须为第二天可能打来的下一个电话做好准备。
day. They came up with a plan. They deactivated a majority of payphones in the area and keep a covert eye on the few they left in order. This would hopefully force the perpetrator to one of the phones that was under surveillance. The selected p-phones were set to go down just after midday on Wednesday June 5. At 11.45am, 15 minutes before the scheduled shutdown, the phone rang at the Smith family's home. Hilda answered. Hello! Hello carefully.
他们制定了一个计划。他们停用了该地区的大部分公用电话，并对剩下的几部电话进行秘密监视。这有望迫使肇事者使用其中一部处于监控下的电话。选定的公用电话定于6月5日星期三中午过后关闭。上午11点45分，即预定关闭时间前15分钟，史密斯家的电话响了。希尔达接了电话。“喂！喂，仔细听。”
Take highway 378 west. Traffic circle. Take from spare tickets. Go one and a half miles. Turn right at side. New slots, number 103. Go one quarter mile. Turn left.
“走378号高速公路向西。交通环岛。从备用票据处走。走一英里半。在侧面右转。新地块，103号。走四分之一英里。左转。”
And wide frame building. Go for back yard. Six feet down. We're waiting. God showed up. Turn left and wide frame building room for backyard. Six feet down that we're waiting. God chose us. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors.
“宽框架建筑。去后院。地下六英尺。我们在等。上帝出现了。左转，宽框架建筑，后院空间。地下六英尺，我们在等。上帝选择了我们。”案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。
Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. The location that Sherry Smith's abductor described was in Saluda County, roughly 17 miles west from the Smith family home. By this point, Sherry had been missing for five days and investigators feared the worst. They ordered Sherry's family to stay home while they followed the caller's instructions, taking extra precautions in anticipation for what they may find. But the family remained tirelessly optimistic that Shari would be found alive, with her mother Hilda preparing an overnight bag in anticipation of a hospital stay. A helicopter was dispatched to the
感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。雪莉·史密斯的绑架者所描述的地点位于萨卢达县，距离史密斯家向西约17英里。此时，雪莉已经失踪了五天，调查人员担心最坏的情况。他们命令史密斯一家待在家里，同时他们按照来电者的指示前往，并为可能发现的情况采取了额外的预防措施。但家人依然怀着乐观的态度，坚信雪莉会被活着找到，她的母亲希尔达甚至准备了一个过夜包，以备住院之需。一架直升机被派往
Masonic Lodge, a white two-story building surrounded by dense woodland. With their aerial view, those on board could see something through the trees roughly 50 feet behind the lodge, about eight feet into the woods. It was the unmistakable side of a human body. A team of officers quickly converged on the scene. 17-year-old Sherry Smith was lying face up on her back, barefoot, and dressed in the same clothes she'd been wearing on the day she went missing. Her shirt was pulled over her body in a manner one investigator described as, like a shroud. All of the jury Sherry had been wearing at the time of her abduction was missing, except for a gold necklace given to her by her boyfriend Richard and a single gold stud earring.
共济会会所，这是一座被茂密林地环绕的白色两层建筑。通过空中视野，机上人员可以看到会所后方约50英尺处，深入树林约八英尺的地方有些东西。那是清晰可见的人体侧影。一队警官迅速赶往现场。17岁的雪莉·史密斯仰面躺着，赤着脚，穿着她失踪当天所穿的衣服。她的衬衫被拉过身体，一位调查员形容这“就像一件寿衣”。雪莉在被绑架时佩戴的所有首饰都不见了，只剩下一条她男友理查德送的金项链和一只金耳钉。
It was immediately clear that Sherry had been deceased for several days. The recent heat wave had caused rapid decomposition, making it impossible to readily determine the cause or time of her death. However, investigators were fairly certain they knew exactly what time Shari had passed away. During his June 4 phone call to Hilda and Dawn Smith, the perpetrator said that he and Sherry had become one soul at 4.58am on June 1. This was likely the time she had died.
很明显，雪莉已经去世好几天了。最近的热浪导致了尸体迅速腐烂，使得无法立即确定死亡原因或死亡时间。然而，调查人员相当确定他们准确地知道了雪莉去世的时间。在6月4日给希尔达和道恩·史密斯的电话中，肇事者说他和雪莉在6月1日凌晨4点58分合二为一。这很可能就是她死亡的时间。
If this was accurate, a man Sherry had passed away just 12 hours after she'd been kidnapped. While this would have been enough time for Sherry to fall sick as a result of her diabetes, it wouldn't have been life threatening. It was therefore unlikely that she died from her medical condition. But Sherry's bodies showed no signs of physical violence such as a gunshot or stab wounds, and no evidence
如果这是准确的，雪莉在被绑架后仅12小时就去世了。虽然这段时间足以让雪莉因糖尿病而生病，但这并不足以致命。因此，她不太可能死于这种疾病。但雪莉的尸体没有显示出任何身体暴力的迹象，如枪伤或刺伤，也没有性侵犯的证据。
of sexual assault. The only identifiable clue as to her cause of death was residue from duct tape that was found on her face, which indicated the possibility that Shari had been suffocated. The killer had also cut a significant chunk of hair from Shari's head, likely to remove duct tape that had gotten stark. Regardless of the exact cause of death, a pathologist determined that whoever had kidnapped Shari was directly responsible. Her death would therefore be treated as a homicide, no matter what. as a homicide, no matter what. A thorough examination of the surrounding woods failed to provide any further evidence. However, a line of saplings leading to Sherry's body had been flattened down, indicating that
唯一可识别的死因线索是她脸上发现的胶带残留物，这表明雪莉可能被窒息而死。凶手还剪掉了雪莉头上的一大块头发，很可能是为了去除粘住的胶带。无论确切死因如何，病理学家确定绑架雪莉的人负有直接责任。因此，无论如何，她的死亡都将被视为他杀。对周围树林的彻底检查未能提供任何进一步的证据。然而，通往雪莉尸体的一排树苗被压平了，这表明
Sherry's killer had likely driven to the back of the Masonic lodge, and then dragged her body about eight feet into the woods. The sheer accuracy of the directions provided by the caller strengthened the investigators belief that he had indeed been returning to visit Sherry's corpse. However, they didn't think that was the reason he delayed revealing the location. It was more likely that the killer was buying time, knowing that the longer Sherry's body lay undiscovered, the less chance there would be of recovering crucial forensic evidence. If this was the case, it bolstered the theory that the killer was familiar with criminal proceedings. The location of the crime scene also strengthened the belief that the killer lived locally. The Masonic lodge was in a remote area with no foot traffic, not the type of place you'd
雪莉的凶手很可能开车到了共济会会所的后面，然后将她的尸体拖进了树林约八英尺处。来电者提供的方向极其准确，这加强了调查人员的信念，即他确实一直在回去探望雪莉的尸体。然而，他们认为这并不是他推迟透露地点的原因。更有可能的是，凶手在争取时间，因为他知道雪莉的尸体被发现得越晚，找回关键法医证据的机会就越小。如果情况确实如此，这就加强了凶手熟悉刑事诉讼程序的理论。犯罪现场的位置也加强了凶手是当地人的看法。共济会会所位于一个偏远地区，没有人行交通，不是那种你会
stumble upon by accident. Sherries family were anxiously sitting at home holding a silent prayer when they saw a patrol car heading down their driveway. They immediately knew that Sherry was dead. As Dawn later described to TV series Eye Witness, Hilda immediately fell apart, sobbing. Not my Sherry, not my baby. Dawn recalled,
偶然闯入的地方。史密斯一家正焦虑地坐在家里进行无声的祈祷，这时他们看到一辆巡逻车驶向他们的车道。他们立刻知道雪莉死了。正如道恩后来向电视节目《目击者》描述的那样，希尔达立刻崩溃了，啜泣着。“不是我的雪莉，不是我的宝贝。”道恩回忆道，
I'd never heard crying like that until that moment. When the news reached the Lexington community, an outpouring of grief was accompanied by an increasing sense of fear. If Sherry's killer wasn't identified, what would stop him from striking again. Friends of Shari's fear today could be targeted next. Her co-workers from the flea market grew increasingly afraid that the strange man who had harassed Shari was responsible and would set his sights on them. On the afternoon of Thursday June 6, Sheriff Matt's hold a press conference appealing to the
“在那一刻之前，我从未听过那样的哭声。”当消息传到列克星敦社区时，悲痛的宣泄伴随着日益增长的恐惧感。如果雪莉的凶手没有被查出，什么能阻止他再次行凶？雪莉的朋友们担心下一个目标可能是自己。她在跳蚤市场的同事们越来越担心那个曾骚扰过雪莉的陌生男人就是罪魁祸首，并将目光投向了她们。6月6日星期四下午，马特警长召开新闻发布会，直接呼吁
perpetrator directly. Matt stated, We are concerned that this person may take his own life if he doesn't turn himself in. We don't want him to do that. I want to reassure him that we have no intentions of killing anyone. All we want to do is take this person into custody. We're trying to get this person to surrender. He needs help and we want him to get it.
肇事者。马特说：“我们担心如果此人不自首，他可能会自杀。我们不希望他这样做。我想向他保证，我们无意杀害任何人。我们只想将此人拘留。我们正在努力让他投降。他需要帮助，我们希望他得到帮助。”
If he's having fun jerking us around, he can continue. The investigation is going full blast and we are not stopping until we catch him. I promise. Charlie Keys was a well-known investigative reporter with local Columbia News Station, WIS. Two and a half hours after the press conference, Charlie was in his office when he received a phone call from an unfamiliar male, who explained that the call was regarding
“如果他以戏弄我们为乐，他可以继续。调查正在全力进行，在我们抓住他之前，我们不会停止。我保证。”查理·基斯是当地哥伦比亚新闻台WIS的一名知名调查记者。新闻发布会两个半小时后，查理在办公室接到了一个陌生男子的电话，对方解释说电话是关于
Shari face Smith. He said that he wanted to use Charlie as a medium, ordering, listen carefully, I can't live with myself Charlie and I need to turn myself in. I'm afraid. The caller gave Charlie a set of instructions. Once they ended their conversation, Charlie was the call Sheriff James Metz and let him know this was no hoax. To prove that he was the one responsible for Sherry's abduction, the caller described Sherry's last will and testament in detail. Charlie was to appear on the news that evening to broadcast Sheriff Matt's home phone number
雪莉·费伊·史密斯的。他说他想把查理当作媒介，命令道：“仔细听，查理，我无法面对自己，我需要自首。我很害怕。”来电者给了查理一套指示。谈话结束后，查理打电话给詹姆斯·马特警长，让他知道这不是恶作剧。为了证明他是绑架雪莉的罪魁祸首，来电者详细描述了雪莉的遗嘱。查理要在当晚的新闻节目中广播马特警长的家庭电话号码，
as proof that the message had been received. The following morning, Charlie was to go to the Sheriff's home, along with the Sherry's priest. The caller promised he would call them then and turn himself in. He would then give Charlie an exclusive interview in which he'd reveal every detail about Shari's abduction. The caller explained, It just went bad.
作为收到信息的证明。第二天早上，查理要和雪莉的牧师一起去警长家。来电者承诺他那时会给他们打电话并自首。然后他会给查理一个独家采访，揭露关于雪莉绑架案的所有细节。来电者解释说：“事情搞砸了。”
I know her family, and well, I just made a mistake. It went too far. All I wanted to do was to make love to her. I didn't know she had the rare disease, and it just got out of hand. I got scared, and I have to do the right thing. All calls me to the new station were automatically recorded, so when Charlie got off the phone, he was able to notify investigators immediately. When they heard the audio, they had no doubt that the voice belonged to Sherry's killer.
“我认识她的家人，嗯，我只是犯了一个错误。事情做得太过分了。我只想和她亲热。我不知道她有这种罕见的疾病，事情失控了。我害怕了，我必须做正确的事。”所有打到新闻台的电话都会自动录音，所以当查理挂断电话后，他能够立即通知调查人员。当他们听到录音时，他们毫不怀疑声音属于雪莉的凶手。
However, they were highly skeptical of the callers claim that he was going to turn himself in. He was getting far too much enjoyment from the power he wielded in this situation. It had been an agonizing day for Shari's loved ones as they came to terms with the reality that Shari would never be coming home. The Thursday evening news came and went without Charlie Keys fulfilling the killer's request to make a public television announcement. Things were quiet at the Smith residence. Bob was at the funeral home making arrangements for his daughter's burial while Hilda was
然而，他们对来电者声称要自首的说法持高度怀疑态度。他从在这种情况下掌握的权力中获得了太多的乐趣。对于雪莉的亲人来说，这是痛苦的一天，他们不得不接受雪莉永远不会回家的现实。周四晚间新闻播出了，查理·基斯并没有履行凶手要求进行电视公开声明的请求。史密斯家很安静。鲍勃在殡仪馆为女儿的葬礼做安排，而希尔达则
in a sedated sleep. At 8.57pm, the phone rang. Sherries aren't Bevelie answered. A telephone operator announced that she had a collect call for Dawn Smith. Bevelie responded that Dawn couldn't come to the phone. A male voice then came on the line and asked to speak with Hilda or Bob Smith. Realising who she was talking to, Beverly went to find Dawn.
在镇静剂的作用下沉睡。晚上8点57分，电话响了。雪莉的姨妈贝弗利接了电话。电话接线员宣布有一个打给道恩·史密斯的对方付费电话。贝弗利回答说道恩不能接电话。一个男人的声音随后出现在线上，要求与希尔达或鲍勃·史密斯通话。意识到自己在和谁说话，贝弗利去找道恩。
As soon as Dawn picked up the phone, she recognized the muffled voice of her sister's killer. The caller told Dawn that he would be turning himself in the following morning. He claimed that Shari had requested he do so on the fifth day after her body was found. He explained that he would no longer be giving an exclusive interview to Charlie Kees. However, he had written a detailed letter describing exactly what happened to Shari, along with pictures, and both Thorn and Charlie would be receiving a copy. Dawn urged the caller not to take his own life. She said she wanted to help him and that God would always forgive. The caller responded that he couldn't live with himself, nor could he live in prison
道恩一接起电话，就认出了她妹妹凶手那低沉的声音。来电者告诉道恩，他将在第二天早上自首。他声称雪莉要求他在她尸体被发现后的第五天这样做。他解释说他不会再接受查理·基斯的独家采访。然而，他写了一封详细的信，描述了雪莉身上到底发生了什么，并附有照片，道恩和查理都会收到一份副本。道恩恳求来电者不要自杀。她说她想帮助他，上帝会宽恕一切。来电者回答说他无法面对自己，也无法在监狱里生活，
or face the electric chair. I'm sick, he said. This is the way it's going to have to be. The caller went on to explain that Shari was very strong-willed and didn't cry once during her ordeal. She wasn't scared, he said. She knew that she was going to be an angel. He claimed that Shari wanted her family to treasure her gold necklace and start earing. He then made a disturbing offer.
或者面对电椅。“我病了，”他说。“事情只能这样了。”来电者继续解释说，雪莉意志非常坚定，在整个折磨过程中一次都没有哭。“她不害怕，”他说。“她知道她会成为天使。”他声称雪莉希望她的家人珍藏她的金项链和耳钉。然后他提出了一个令人不安的提议。
Did Dawn want to know how her sister died? Dawn said yes. According to the caller, he gave Shari the option. Did she want to be suffocated, shot, or given a drug overdose? want to be suffocated, shot, or given a drug overdose. She chose suffocation. Shari then wrote her last will and testament at her own volition. The caller then, quote, made love to Shari before tying her to the bedpost with electrical cord. He proceeded to cover her head with duct tape until she could no longer breathe. Dawn asked if Sherry had been afraid.
道恩想知道她妹妹是怎么死的吗？道恩说是。据来电者说，他给了雪莉选择权。她想被窒息、枪杀还是药物过量？她选择了窒息。雪莉随后自愿写下了她的遗嘱。来电者随后“与雪莉亲热”，然后用电线把她绑在床柱上。他继续用胶带蒙住她的头，直到她无法呼吸。道恩问雪莉是否害怕。
The caller responded, she was not, she was at peace, she knew that God was with her. The call was traced to a truck stop roughly 50 miles from the Smithsome in the town of Great Falls. Yet again, the caller had left behind no evidence. But his latest phone call had been significantly longer than the others, and provided investigators with some deeper insights. Like in his call to Charlie Keys, the perpetrator had told Dorn that he was a friend of the family, but his claims that he didn't know Shari had a rare medical condition disproved this assertion.
来电者回答说：“她没有，她很平静，她知道上帝与她同在。”电话被追踪到距离史密斯家约50英里的格雷特福尔斯镇的一个卡车停靠站。同样，来电者没有留下任何证据。但他最近的这个电话比之前的电话长得多，并为调查人员提供了一些更深入的见解。就像在给查理·基斯的电话中一样，肇事者告诉道恩他是家里的朋友，但他声称不知道雪莉患有罕见疾病，这反驳了这一说法。
Shari's diabetes was a well-known fact among her in a circle, and if the perpetrator knew the Smiths, he would have been aware of this. Additionally, investigators highly doubted that he would have given Shari the choice of how she died. As Profiler John Douglas explained in his book when a killer calls, even if this was true, it was incredibly dubious that Shari would have chosen suffocation. To Douglas, quote,
雪莉的糖尿病在她的圈子里是众所周知的事实，如果肇事者认识史密斯一家，他应该知道这一点。此外，调查人员非常怀疑他会给雪莉选择死亡方式的机会。正如行为分析专家约翰·道格拉斯在他的书《当杀手来电时》中所解释的那样，即使这是真的，雪莉选择窒息的可能性也极其可疑。对道格拉斯来说，
He chose this means because it prolonged his sexual thrill at the power he had over her, and the length of time he got to enjoy watching her die. But there was something else the caller said that had investigators on edge. But there was something else the caller said that had investigators on edge. At the start of the call, he'd mistakenly said that all he'd wanted to do was make love to Dawn. Dawn and Shari looked strikingly similar and they were sometimes mistaken for twins. Given that the perpetrator had specifically asked to speak with Dawn and appeared to be attempting to establish a bond between them, concerns were raised that he could be turning his focus
“他选择这种方式是因为它延长了他对她所拥有的权力的性快感，以及他享受观看她死亡的时间长度。”但来电者说的还有其他事情让调查人员感到不安。在电话开始时，他错误地说他只想和道恩亲热。道恩和雪莉长得非常像，有时被误认为是双胞胎。鉴于肇事者特别要求与道恩通话，并且似乎试图在他们之间建立联系，人们担心他可能会将注意力转向
on Dawn. If John Douglas's behavioural profile was anything to go by, the killer wouldn't stop with sherry. What if Dawn was next? The Smith family was warned of this possibility, but they had no choice but to persevere. Just as investigators suspected, the killer didn't turn himself in on Friday lucky it promised. Saturday June 8 was Sherry's funeral. Over 1,000 mourners gathered to farewell the 17-year-old
道恩。如果约翰·道格拉斯的行为分析有任何参考价值的话，凶手不会在雪莉身上停止。如果下一个是道恩呢？史密斯一家被警告了这种可能性，但他们别无选择，只能坚持下去。正如调查人员所怀疑的那样，凶手并没有像承诺的那样在周五自首。6月8日星期六是雪莉的葬礼。超过1,000名哀悼者聚集在一起，为这位17岁的女孩送行
at Lexington's first Baptist Church. Sherry's murder had a profound impact on the local community, and Lexington's citizens tied pink ribbons to signposts and ladder boxes between the church and cemetery as a sign of respect. Sherry's pastor urged to those in attendance not to blame God, saying, God does not do what has been done here. It is because of the confusion and the sin and the depravity of men that we've come to an occasion like this. Investigators believed there was a high chance that Shari's killer was among the attendees.
在列克星敦第一浸信会教堂。雪莉的谋杀案对当地社区产生了深远的影响，列克星敦的市民在教堂和墓地之间的路标和邮箱上系上了粉红色的丝带，以示尊重。雪莉的牧师敦促出席者不要责怪上帝，他说：“上帝不会做这里所做的事情。正是因为人类的混乱、罪恶和堕落，我们才来到这样的场合。”调查人员认为，雪莉的凶手很有可能就在出席者之中。
They filmed at the proceedings and were on high alert for anything out of the ordinary. At the cemetery, as the graveside service wrapped up, a man in his 30s suddenly leapt from the crowd. I'm sorry, I'm really sorry," he shouted. Whoever is responsible for this, I believe you're here. I love you and I will not hurt you. Come forward right now." His sudden outburst caused such alarm that one of Sherry's friends fell to the ground screaming in terror. The man immediately became a suspect, even more so when it was revealed that he owned
他们拍摄了整个过程，并对任何异常情况保持高度警惕。在墓地，当墓边仪式结束时，一名30多岁的男子突然从人群中跳了出来。“对不起，我真的很抱歉，”他喊道。“无论谁对此负责，我相信你就在这里。我爱你，我不会伤害你。现在就站出来。”他突然的爆发引起了极大的恐慌，以至于雪莉的一位朋友尖叫着倒在地上。这名男子立即成为嫌疑人，当发现他拥有一辆
a car similar to the one seen near the Smith's driveway on the day Sherry was abducted. He was taken in for police questioning and had his voice compared to the audio of the killer, but it didn't match and there was nothing to link him to the crime. The shaken Smith family had only just returned home from the funeral when at 2.21pm, the phone rang. Dawn answered, with the operator telling her it was a collect call from Shari. After accepting the charges, Dawn was once again met by the voice of her sister's killer. He told her he'd been at the funeral and that a police officer had directed him into a parking space.
与雪莉被绑架当天在史密斯家车道附近看到的汽车相似的车辆时，嫌疑更大了。他被带去接受警方审讯，并将他的声音与凶手的录音进行了对比，但不匹配，也没有任何证据将他与犯罪联系起来。惊魂未定的史密斯一家刚从葬礼回到家，下午2点21分，电话响了。道恩接了电话，接线员告诉她这是一个来自雪莉的对方付费电话。在接受了费用后，道恩再次听到了她妹妹凶手的声音。他告诉她他参加了葬礼，一名警官还指挥他停进了停车位。
For several minutes he ranted about his final interactions with Shari, speaking as though the two of them had a close relationship and that sherry viewed him as a confidant. Dawn asked the caller why he didn't turn himself in as promised. He responded, I didn't have the strength, I'm scared as hell. He refused to tell Dawn where he had killed sherry, saying only that it happened in Lexington County. However, he claimed he did want to reveal this information.
几分钟来，他喋喋不休地谈论着他与雪莉的最后互动，说话的语气好像他们两人关系密切，雪莉把他当作知己。道恩问来电者为什么没有像承诺的那样自首。他回答说：“我没有勇气，我吓坏了。”他拒绝告诉道恩他在哪里杀害了雪莉，只说它发生在列克星敦县。然而，他声称他确实想透露这个信息。
He promised a dawn he'd call again the following Saturday with the exact location, concluding the call. God bless us all. to bless us all. The call was traced to a gas station in the neighboring state of Georgia, roughly 60 miles from the Smith's home. Predictively, there was no sign of the killer nor any clues left behind. The days ticked by are with no further word from him. Investigators remained unconvinced that he could have taken his own life. He was enjoying himself too much.
他向道恩承诺下周六会再次打电话告知确切地点，并结束了通话。“上帝保佑我们所有人。”电话被追踪到邻近佐治亚州的一个加油站，距离史密斯家约60英里。不出所料，没有凶手的踪迹，也没有留下任何线索。日子一天天过去，没有他进一步的消息。调查人员仍然不相信他会自杀。他玩得太开心了。
Sheriff Matt's told the press, I don't think he has the guts. If he was going to do it, he'd have done it by now. The manhunt intensified as the reward for information increased to $30,000. Investigators examined the footage from Sherry's funeral on the lookout for anyone even remotely suspicious. A segment about Sherry's case was aired on the local Crime Stoppers TV program, with the sheriff Matt's telling the public, somebody somewhere knows the killer.
马特警长告诉媒体：“我不认为他有那个胆量。如果他要自杀，他早就做了。”随着悬赏金增加到30,000美元，搜捕行动加强了。调查人员检查了雪莉葬礼的录像，寻找任何哪怕有一点可疑的人。关于雪莉案件的一个片段在当地的“灭罪热线”电视节目中播出，马特警长告诉公众：“某人、某处一定知道凶手是谁。”
We've got to find this person before he kills again. Hundreds of tips came through to the police, but the days continued to go by with no arrests. Gunsails rose around South Carolina, with several households reporting receiving threatening phone calls against their children. Although the killer's silence was mystifying, investigators believed it was only a matter of time before the perpetrator made further contact with Dawn. She was given instructions on how to behave if he called again. Given his hunger for power, Dawn was told to be compassionate and understanding so that
“我们必须在他再次杀人之前找到这个人。”数百条线索传到了警方，但日子一天天过去，依然没有逮捕任何人。南卡罗来纳州的枪支销售额上升，几户人家报告收到了针对他们孩子的威胁电话。尽管凶手的沉默令人困惑，但调查人员认为，他再次联系道恩只是时间问题。她被告知如果他再次打电话该如何表现。鉴于他对权力的渴望，道恩被告知要表现得富有同情心和理解力，这样
he would feel like the one in charge. The longer she could keep him talking, the better their chances were at tracing the call. But despite his promise to call the following Saturday, a week came and went with no further contact from the killer. Concerns arose that he could have fled into state where he could be on the hunt for his next victim. If experience had taught the investigative team anything, it was that killers of this nature didn't simply stop. If he wasn't apprehended, there were no doubts that he would kill again.
他会觉得他是掌控全局的人。她能让他说话的时间越长，他们追踪电话的机会就越大。但尽管他承诺下周六打电话，一周过去了，凶手没有进一步联系。人们担心他可能已经逃到州外，在那里他可能正在寻找下一个受害者。如果经验教训了调查小组什么，那就是这种性质的杀手不会轻易停止。如果他不被逮捕，毫无疑问他会再次杀人。
Investigators wondered whether they could lure the killer out by using Dawn as a sort of pawn. Sherries would be 18th birthday was approaching. Profiler John Douglas devised a plan. What if they held a memorial service for Shari on her birthday and made sure it was covered by the media? This just might reignite the killer's interest in dawn. Shari collected a stuffed koalas. Dawn could lay one on Sherry's grave in the hopes that the killer might be tempted to steal it as a memento. covert officers could lay in wait with around the clock surveillance ready to capture any suspicious activity. Dawn was apprehensive about the plan, but she was prepared to go to any length to capture her sister's
调查人员想知道他们是否可以通过利用道恩作为某种诱饵来引出凶手。雪莉的18岁生日即将到来。行为分析专家约翰·道格拉斯制定了一个计划。如果他们为雪莉的生日举行追悼会，并确保媒体报道呢？这可能会重新点燃凶手对道恩的兴趣。雪莉收集毛绒考拉。道恩可以在雪莉的坟墓上放一个，希望凶手可能会被诱惑去偷它作为纪念品。秘密警官可以全天候监视，准备捕捉任何可疑活动。道恩对这个计划感到忧虑，但她准备不惜一切代价抓住她妹妹的
killer. The memorial was scheduled to go ahead on Tuesday June 25. Three days prior, just after midnight on Saturday June 22, the phone rang at the Smith family home. Dawn answered. The operator told her it was a collect call from Shari Faith Smith. Dawn accepted. Thank you, Dawn. You know this isn't a hoax, correct?
凶手。追悼会定于6月25日星期二举行。三天前，6月22日星期六午夜刚过，史密斯家的电话响了。道恩接了电话。接线员告诉她这是一个来自雪莉·费伊·史密斯的对方付费电话。道恩接受了。“谢谢你，道恩。你知道这不是恶作剧，对吧？”
Came the all-too-familiar voice. He continued. You know, God wants you to join Chari Faye. This month, next month, this year, next year. You can't be protected all the time. Have you heard about Deborah May Hamrick? So be continued, next week. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那个太熟悉的声音传了过来。他继续说：“你知道，上帝希望你加入雪莉·费伊。这个月，下个月，今年，明年。你不可能一直受到保护。你听说过黛博拉·梅·哈姆里克吗？”所以，下周继续。你。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。